alrighty folks so christmas is just
around the corner you know what that
means the best christmas movies they're
all going to be on tv so today we're
going to go through some of my favorite
christmas movies this video is sponsored
by expressvpn
all righty let's begin with the shop
around the corner this is an ernest
lubitz classic there was something
called the lubish touch for people who
don't know old film ernest lubich was
famous for making these very
nostalgic and and charming films that
really kind of tugged at the
heartstrings later the film would be
remade as you've got mail with tom hanks
and meg ryan but the original film is
actually based on a hungarian play the
movie is jimmy stewart very very young
jimmy stewart this is 1940 and margaret
sullivan and the basic plot is the same
as the plot of you've got male it's
these two people who live next door to
one another and they end up
corresponding via the mail and they fall
in love that way he figures out earlier
than she does that he is corresponding
with her but she has no clue she
despises him she thinks he's terrible
there's this very charming romance it's
it's really a a bit of a a tear-jerker
and it's definitely a film that stands
the test of time alrighty next we've got
meet me in saint louis so this is a judy
garland classic so if you're going to
make a list of the best judy garland
movies this one is a top five the best
judy garland movies obviously wizard of
oz at the top of the list a star is born
with james mason is near the top of the
list mimi and st louis is a classic it's
got a great score margaret o'brien who's
the little sister to judy garland she
actually won an oscar for this some of
the best child crying you have ever seen
is in this film it also is famous
because of the classic song from meet me
in saint louis have yourself a merry
little christmas which is from this
original movie in his judy garland
singing it what's hilarious about that
song is that the original lyrics that
song are super dark because the movie
actually takes place around the world
fair in st louis turn of the century and
the idea is that the entire family is
considering picking up and moving from
st louis to new york and so the entire
movie is about whether they're going to
do this or not judy garland is falling
in love with the boy next door and all
this little girl really doesn't want to
go and so there's a point where she runs
outside and she smashes all of the
snowmen that they've made out in the
snow and judy garland then sings to her
have yourself a merry little christmas
and it's sort of at the turning point of
the film so the original lyric to that
song is not have yourself a merry little
christmas let your heart be light the
original lyric to the song was have
yourself a merry little christmas it may
be your last next year we may all be
living in the past so yeah they they
decided not to go with the super dark
version and uh then they created a
christmas classic out of the song
alrighty next while you were sleeping so
an actual great modern rom-com naturally
that means there's a bunch of stuff in
there that wouldn't make the cut today
like there's a character who likes
wearing women's shoes and this is played
for a joke now of course that would be
considered transphobic to make a joke
out of that but the movie is quirky and
charming and still really fun to watch
it is young excellent sandra bullock and
bill pullman who of course plays bill
pullman he's the same person in every
single film there's never been a movie
with bill pullman where bill pullman is
not bill pullman i'm a prince but it is
it is sandra bullock and bill pullman
who plays the brother of a guy who
basically is knocked out and he's
knocked out the entire film he's in a
coma and she pretends to be his fiancee
well he's knocked out and ends up
falling in love with bill pullman who is
the brother it's a really charming film
that ends with with a christmas
celebration already next on the list the
bishop's wife so this is sort of a
forgotten classic they tried to remake
it as the preacher's wife denzel
washington it's not nearly as good a
film the basic movie is about david
niven who plays a bishop and he really
really wants to build this this new
church and his wife is loretta young and
he's kind of ignoring her and and what
she wants and and her desire to build a
family because he's so focused in on he
is going to build this church and cary
grant plays an angel who shows up and
essentially begins wooing loretta young
and it's just peak cary grant cary grant
is definitely the most charming movie
star ever it it is not closed i'm not
sure even who the close competitors
would be yeah i think the reason they
recast this with denzel washington is
because denzel was probably the closest
thing but cary grant just had a unique
charm to him on screen the movie is
great it's really rewatchable it's
really funny because everything with
cary grant is is charming and the entire
message is about how if you put solely
spiritual pursuits above the
quasi-humanistic concerns of your own
family you're doing it wrong you're
supposed to have spiritual pursuits via
your family and that's the best way to
be both a good christian and from my
view a good jew as well alrighty it's a
wonderful life which isn't just the best
christmas film it it may be the best
film it's a wonderful life it's an
amazing amazing movie obviously it
requires very little introduction you
got jimmy stewart he got lydle barrymore
and a cast of thousands and the entire
film is a play on a christmas carol the
first half of the film is really really
dark and people forget how dark the
performance the jimmy stewart gives in
this film is so jimmy stewart was was
famous for being sort of slap sticky and
very jimmy stewart in this film he gets
angry when he plays angry it actually
works jimmy stewart underrated actor and
jimmy stewart is this guy who feels
hemmed in by life and he's started this
bank and and now he's lost all the money
because his dumb uncle who's a drunk
idiot has lost all the cash and lionel
barrymore is taking advantage of him and
he thinks about killing himself and he's
convinced not to by being shown what the
world would be like had he not been born
and then of course the community comes
around to save him it is the ultimate
christmas movie it's about forgiveness
it is about community it's about the
unseen contributions that we all make to
the lives of the people around us now
also lionel barrymore is correct so on a
financial level the villain of this
piece is actually the hero because if
jimmy stewart actually gets his way all
of bedford falls collapses in the
subprime mortgage crisis basically jimmy
stewart keeps giving out loans without
proper checking into the credit history
of the people he's giving loans to based
on his sort of assessment of their own
personal viability financially lionel
barrymore is much more by the numbers
leno barrymore is a better banker and
and that local bank probably goes under
so the movie was supposed to be sort of
a quasi-socialistic fdr parable but the
reality is that the real estate policies
followed by jimmy stewart bankrupt
bedford falls and everybody ends up
homeless we'll get to more on favorite
christmas movies in just one second
first a few decades ago private citizens
used to be largely that private what
changed well you know the internet think
about everything you've browsed searched
for watched or tweeted now imagine all
of that data being crawled through
collected aggregated by third parties
into a permanent public record your
record having your private life exposed
for others to see was once something
only celebrities worried about but in an
era where everyone is online everyone is
in fact a public figure to keep my data
private when i go online i use
expressvpn did you know there are
hundreds of data brokers out there who
sold businesses to buy and sell your
data the worst part they don't have to
tell you who you're selling it to or get
your consent one of the data points is
your ip address data harvesters use your
ip to uniquely identify you and your
location but with expressvpn my
connection gets rerouted through an
encrypted server and my ip address is
masked every time i turn expressvpn on
i'm given a random ip address shared by
other expressvpn customers that makes it
much more difficult for third parties to
identify me and to harvest my data the
best part is how easy expressvpn is to
use no matter what device you are on
phone laptop smart tv all you have to do
is tap one button to get protected so if
you like me believe your data is your
business secure yourself with the number
one rated vpn on the market visit
expressvpn.com ben get three extra
months for free that's expr essvpn.com
ben go to expressvpn.com ben to learn
more
all righty next up is a christmas story
definitely the funniest christmas movie
ever made my family and i quote this one
all the time again there are a bunch of
aspects to this film that just would not
be allowed today from the mockery of the
chinese accent at the very end of the
movie to the treatment of the leg lamp
but it is a very very funny film it is a
great window into what childhood is like
because again the whole movie is written
from the perspective of childhood the
great gravitas that is brought to it by
the narrator very few movies with the
narrator actually work this one the
narrator actually works really really
well and it's hysterical when this movie
came out it was actually kind of a
massive bomb it didn't do really well
when it came out at the box office and
then it started getting shown on tv and
then more and more people engaged with
it to the point they actually ended up
making a broadway musical out of it and
it's become sort of an iconic piece
about the season home alone a classic
for the kids it is kind of weird that
you end up with joe pesci and daniel
stern in those roles because it is
really strange particularly pesci that's
a weird piece of casting so joe pesci
goes on a real run he's got good fellas
home alone jfk
my cousin vinnie lethal weapons two and
three are sandwiched somewhere in here
so that's a big run for for joe pesci
right in here so think of an actor you
would cast in both home alone and also
good fellows so he's terrifying in good
fellas obviously and then in home alone
he's just this slap sticky guy and joe
pesce is kind of a shocker because the
guy actually has a bit of rage right and
then daniel stern is on sort of a
bizarre run of his own so he's done
diner a little bit earlier in the 80s
and then he's in one of my favorite
films called breaking away from 1979
which is really a terrific film
underrated film that one's got like
dennis quaid and daniel stern and jackie
earl haley a very young jackie earl
haley really good movie you should check
it out um but here you've got daniel
stern in the middle of like a pretty
good comedic run he's got home alone he
has city slickers and then a couple
years later he has rookie of the year so
a little bit of a daniel stern
renaissance right here and of course
we'd be remiss if we didn't do andrew
clavin's favorite one christmas carol of
course that is his favorite actual piece
of writing ever charles dickens
christmas carol they've made it 1 000
times with a thousand different actors
the best version is the i believe it's
1951 version with aleister sim that's a
really really good movie and really
super creepy so go check that out if
you're looking for a christmas carol
finally die hard how could this not be a
christmas movie i don't even understand
why this is even an argument the entire
plot is written around christmas i mean
they're constantly using the ode to joy
and they have the ho ho ho now i have a
machine gun and they're playing at the
very close the weather outside is
rightful they've got the papers coming
down like snow the whole thing is a
christmas movie stop it merry christmas
unless what you believe is a christmas
movie is just something that is in line
with the thematics of the season
although this one is too right it's
about forgiveness and it's about love
and it's about the true meaning of
christmas which is blowing up large
buildings using plastic explosives it is
a fantastic film and one of the reasons
it's a fantastic film is it's the rare
action film where the villain and the
hero are both great so usually in action
films the villain is great or the hero
is great or neither is great but in this
one you've got a great hero in bruce
willis and then you've got a great
villain in alan rickman and they're both
just a game really bringing it the plot
really works the dialogue really works
it's fantastic it's one of the most
rewatchable movies of all time i mean if
this is on tv and you're just coming in
on any scene you're watching the rest of
the film it is just
that good and you have to love the 80s
touch of it being super anti-japanese
real estate investment in the united
states it is a very 80s movie that's
taking place in the late 80s early 90s
and it's just it's just great it's a
great film john mctiernan who's the
director of this film he has just a
spectacular run right here right he has
a predator in 87 which is a great movie
he has die hard in 88 which is a
fantastic movie and he has hunter in
october in 90 which is a fantastic
fantastic movie and then he makes sort
of a parody of himself with last action
hero highest dead guy
but that three movie set right there
it's hard to imagine a better three
movie set for an action director than
predator diehard hunter in october in
back to back to almost back-to-back
years that is a spectacular run there
from john mcteer and of course this
comes at the height of bruce willis
mania bruce willis had been on
moonlighting which was a fairly big hit
but he had not had a film role that had
really done anything up to this point
and so they'd consider pretty much
everybody for this they thought
schwarzenegger for this role they
thought stallone for this role at one
point they considered kurt russell for
the role they were considering clint
eastwood for the role the origins of die
hard are interesting because they
actually wanted to base it on like a
1966 book called the detective which
they developed into a movie from frank
sinatra and then they took the basic
plot points and they reworked that into
die hard bruce willis was basically
everybody's last idea for the part and
of course it ends up being the role that
launches his career in the movies so
we've gone over a lot of christmas
movies today but the one that truly
embodies the spirit of christmas you
know the birth of the baby jesus is of
course reindeer games with ben affleck
reindeer games alrighty folks
well we have reached the end of our
review of best christmas movies of all
time i hope you enjoyed it if you're
christian have a wonderful christmas if
you're jewish enjoy the chinese food
[Music]